hola soy loren de khan academy quiero
ofrecerte un breve resumen sobre cómo
abrir cuentas para ti y para tus hijos
en khan academy también veremos cómo
encontrar contenido relevante para tus
hijos y cómo ver su progreso este vídeo
está pensado para padres con hijos de 12
años o menores si tu hijo o hija es
mayor te recomendamos ver nuestro vídeo
llamados sugerencias de inicio rápido
para padres niños de 13 años en adelante
vamos a comenzar con los pasos para que
tu hijo abra una cuenta en khan academy
crear una cuenta les va a permitir a ti
ya tu hijo seguir su avance y el tiempo
que le lleva a aprender visita a ese
punto khan academy punto org y haz clic
en regístrate en la esquina superior
derecha en la página de registro
introduce la fecha de nacimiento de tu
hijo y haz clic en regístrate elegir un
nombre de usuario en la siguiente página
escribe tu dirección de correo
electrónico y elige un nombre de usuario
para tu hijo y una contraseña después
haz clic en regístrate
a continuación aparecerá la ventana
emergente personaliza khan academy donde
podrás elegir el punto de partida de la
ruta de aprendizaje de tu hijo en esta
página verás los cursos disponibles
elige uno o más y haz clic en continuar
ahora tu hijo está listo para comenzar
pídele que haga clic en el botón azul de
empezar en cualquier curso para iniciar
con la primera lección también puede
elegir la opción ver todos para navegar
por todo el curso
si no sabes bien en qué nivel está tu
hijo he aquí una sugerencia la mayoría
de los cursos de matemáticas de khan
academy incluye un desafío de curso que
puede ayudarte a identificar los temas
en los que requiere más práctica y en
los que está listo para encontrar esos
desafíos pídele que se desplace hacia
abajo en la página del curso y haga clic
en comenzar el desafío del curso los
desafíos toman normalmente entre 30 y 45
minutos y te darán una muy buena idea de
hacia dónde dirigir su aprendizaje
puedes también hacer que comience un
grado abajo del suyo o incluso en jardín
de niños y avanzar de ahí lo siguiente
es crear una cuenta para padres debes
crear una cuenta de padre dentro de los
siguientes siete días de lo contrario
las cuentas de niño serán eliminadas
para crear una cuenta primero revisa tu
correo electrónico en la bandeja de
entrada tendrás un correo por cada uno
de tus hijos registrados que te pedirá
la aprobación de sus cuentas en khan
academy haz clic en el botón verde que
dice permitir que mi hijo use khan
academy revisa tus actualizaciones y
otras bandejas de correo si no ves este
mensaje inmediatamente sigue las
indicaciones para registrar una nueva
cuenta o entra con una cuenta existente
vinculada con la dirección de correo
electrónico en la que recibiste el
correo una vez registrado se abrirá el
panel de padres si quieres ver el avance
de tu hijo haz clic en su nombre de
usuario
esto te llevará al reporte de avance en
donde podrás ver lo que ha aprendido y
cuánto tiempo le ha llevado tu hijo
también podrá ver este reporte desde su
cuenta
hacer clic en avance en la barra de
navegación a la izquierda gracias por
ver este vídeo
esperamos que tu hijo y tú disfruten de
aprender en khan academy